We have seven more classes left in the
semester and what I want to do in this
last seven classes is look at the game
theory of World War II. Okay. So what I
want to do this class is just introduce
the chess board
or the players
and how the game will be played over the
next 5 to 10 years.
So the two major players in World War II
are the United States
and Russia.
And
right now they are fighting a proxy war
in the Middle East between
Israel
and Iran. where the United States
obviously supports Israel, Russia
supports Iran. And what's going to
happen is that this war
um in the Middle East, it's going to
spread out and it will engulf the entire
world. Okay. So what I want to do today
is look at the individual players USA,
Israel, Iran and Russia and explain to
you who they are and how they will play
this game and and once we understand
their strategy then it's going to be
pretty easy for us to make certain
predictions about how they will behave.
So that's the first thing that I want to
point out. The other thing that I'll
point out is that
there's a lot of people who believe that
peace can be achieved. [snorts] That
this war is a temporary thing and that
once Donald Trump leaves office, once
United States divorces Israel, then
peace will come to the world. And that's
not true because on one hand what's
driving this World War III is a conflict
between these four nations. But on the
other hand, the other force that's
driving this conflict is the internal
tensions within these countries. So
before we looked at the idea of elite
over produ overp production
[snorts and clears throat]
and so the idea is that
the elite are parasites that collect
rent from the people and soever who's in
the elite
um can
exploit other people. So there's
competition to to join the elite and
when you have too many people who are
trying to join the elite this creates
internal conflict and this is what's
happening throughout the world today. So
World War II it's not just being driven
by the disparities
between these four nations. It's really
being driven by
internal
politics within these countries. Okay.
So, so let me put put this in a very
simple way. Right now, the people who
run the world are transnational
capital.
Okay.
And a very simple way of saying this is
that if you're a rich person in Russia,
you are incentivized to work with rich
people in Iran, Israel, and the United
States.
And as a result, for the longest time,
we've been able to achieve global peace
and prosperity.
But because they only get richer and
richer and more powerful, this causes
resentment
among other elite forces in these
countries. And so there are three major
forces that oppose transnational capital
within these four countries. Okay. So,
let's just list them.
The first is of course nationalism,
right? There are people like Donald
Trump and Vladimir Putin who believe
that it's important to put their nation
first,
that globalism is hurting their own
people and their own nation. Okay,
that's so that's one force that opposes
transational capital. Another force that
opposes transaction capital is religion
or orthodoxy. Okay?
Why? Because capital
believes that money is God. It is
godless. It is secular.
And it tries to create a multicultural
secular society in order to allow
capital to pass through society
easily. Okay. that also allows capital
to control and dominate society. So
religion is opposed to national cap
transational capital as well. And the
last force that's opposed to
transational capital is artificial
intelligence. Okay? [snorts]
AI.
Why? Because
right now money is what
um structures society and artificial
intelligence wants to replace money as
the force that structures and center
society. Okay. So in other words, what's
happening is that
there's a civil war going on in the
world where right now transational
capital is dominant and transational
capital is represented by Wall Street
and city of London. And there are these
three forces, nationalism, religion and
technology that oppose transational
capital. And so what's going to happen
over time is that they will form an
alliance to defeat transational capital.
Okay. And so this is already happening
in America where these three forces come
together and to support Donald Trump.
And so what drives a lot of Donald
Trump's policies
is to help his alliance ultimately
defeat transnational capital. Okay? And
something that we'll discuss for the
rest of the semester.
So
another thing that I'll point out is
this.
Okay, internally
there is a civil war going on but
externally as well there are forces that
drive these nations to war and it and
this is basically environmental
collapse.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> So for the past few decades we humans
have been very lucky and that there have
been no major ecological disasters.
But if you look at human history,
weather patterns
fluctuate. Okay. So many speculate that
we are heading towards a time of extreme
weather patterns. That means that it
becomes harder to grow food. It means
it's harder to access energy. And so
this going to put strain on the world.
And so the world needs to compete for
precious resources. And quite honestly,
we are going to probably approach a time
in human history when famine
and it will be much more common.
We fought that. We defeated famine. We
thought that we had developed a system
that could feed anyone and everyone. But
over the next few years, we'll discover
an increase in famine around the world
and an increase in ecological disasters
around the world. Okay? So this is the
schematic that I want you to understand.
In World War II, there will be four
major players. United States, Israel,
Iran, and Russia. And they are competing
for global dominance. No one will win
but the conflict among these four
nations will drive geopolitics for the
next 5 to 10 years. This conflict is
driven not just by
um disputes among these countries. It's
mainly driven by internal civil discord
within these countries.
The two forces are
the transnational capital versus a
coalition of nationalist relig religious
people as well as tech people. Okay. And
they have their champions. So in America
they have Trump uh transational capital
is represented by Carney. Mark Carney.
We'll talk more about him later. Okay.
Mark Carney is currently the prime
minister of Canada. Okay. So they have
there are different champions and
they're going to fight this this war.
Now one question that you're going to
have which is the most obvious question
is yeah but what about everyone else
right? What about China?
What about India?
What about Brazil?
What about South Africa?
Okay. And yes it is true. Oh sorry. And
what about Europe?
and and Japan, right?
And then South Korea.
And while it is true that these are
major economies with a lot of people and
it is true that they could in theory
have great militaries.
I will show you that what makes these
four nations distinct, USA, Israel, Iran
and Russia. What makes them distinct is
that they have a grand strategy that
allows them to mobilize the population
for total war. That's what makes them
distinct. Okay? And I'll show you this
later on. All right? All right. So, um,
let me explain to you
how this dynamic will play out. Okay.
Okay, you have US, A, [snorts] Russia,
um, Iran,
Israel.
Okay. So the major players that
um will determine how these four play
the games are of course Europe
um China,
Japan,
India.
Okay.
All right. So
I understand that a lot a lot of people
believe that China and the United States
are in competition with each other. That
is not true. And the reason why is that
China does not have what we call a grand
strategy.
A grand strategy is just how you
perceive geopolitics and how you want to
dominate geopolitics.
China does not do grand strategy. China
is called
okay
means the middle kingdom. The idea of
the middle kingdom is that we are a
universe onto ourselves. We don't care
what happens outside of this universe.
We would like others to pay tribute to
our cultural superiority and we could
help develop your other civilizations
but honestly we don't care. Okay. So
China has always been an isolationist
society for most of its history. Today
yes I understand for these past few
decades China has become much more
globalized has become much more
international much more cosmopolitan but
this is not
part of the Chinese tradition so what's
happening today these past few decades
it is an aberration it goes against
cultural norms in China but in the long
term China will return to its cultural
norms and become much more isolationist
so we don't so China doesn't really
matter
in the great scheme of things. Okay. The
same is true for India as well. All
right. So I know India and China have
have a lot of people but historically
they have not really mattered in
geopolitics and that's to do with their
cultural values and norms. Okay. Does
that make sense? All right. So um there
are right now
three major battlefields
in the world. Okay. The first obviously
is Ukraine where NATO and Russia are
fighting each other. Okay. And this is a
proxy war between United States and
Russia because United States controls
Europe and NATO. The second major
battlefield of course is Iran where
right now the United States and Israel
is attacking Iran and trying to force it
into a surrender. Now the last
battlefield is actually uh in North
America Cuba. Okay. So this is not
really discussed a lot. What's been
happening is United States has been
embargoing Cuba, trying to blockade it,
trying uh to cause society to collapse
and Russia has been trying to save Cuba.
Okay, so these are the three major
battlefronts we we're seeing right now.
Obviously, what's going to happen is
that more battlefronts will break out.
Okay? And um what's going to happen is
that as this conflict increases
the conf between United States and
Russia will increase as well. So one
major area of contention is um the
oceans.
Okay. Why? Because United States
believes that it controls all trade
access because the oceans represents
trade access.
>> [snorts]
>> And so what the United States has been
doing has is it has been seizing Russian
shadow fleet tankers.
And so what's going to happen is that
the Russians will eventually decide to
arm its ships and this will create a war
in the in the oceans. Okay. So that's
one trend that we will see happening.
Another trend that we'll see happening
is the rise of Germany
and Japan.
Okay.
And why? Well, [clears throat]
historically, the most powerful nation
in Europe has been Germany.
Historically, the most powerful nation
in East Asia has been Japan.
The United States defeated both in World
War II.
And but now that the United States is at
war with Russia, it needs proxies. It
need allies to counter both the threat
of Russia as well as China. So it makes
sense that what the United States is
going to do is it's going to arm Israel
to counter Iran. It's going to arm
Germany to counter Russia. It's going to
arm Japan to counter China. Okay?
[clears throat]
And
what's going to happen now is that you
have new in this conflict. You have
other players emerge
that
will take advantage of these conflicts
to amass more power for themselves. So
think about
North Korea
in East Asia, okay?
Because North Korea it's a military
society and it can threaten South Korea,
Japan and China. Okay. Then in Europe
you have Poland.
Um in the Middle East you have Tur
Turkey.
Okay. So these nations are going to try
to navigate all this chaos in order to
amass more power for themselves. So in
other words, what's going to happen is
complete chaos in World War II. Okay,
this is something that we'll discuss
um more concretely for the rest of the
semester. All right. So now what what I
want to do now is explain to you the
grand strategy of the United States,
Russia, Iran, and Israel because these
are only the four major players for the
first five years. Other players will
come in later on but for now these are
the four major players. Okay. And once
you understand the grand strategy all
these four countries then it's going to
be pretty easy for us to predict how
they will behave as this war progresses.
All right. Okay.
So for each country I want you to
imagine each country
as a chess set. Okay. So this is a chess
set and I want to show you
um how each player behaves using this
chess set as as a template as a frame
frame of reference. Okay. So the king is
the political system.
All right. So the first idea to
understand is that when you fight a war,
you're not trying to defeat the other
person's en military. Doesn't really get
you anywhere. What you're really trying
to do is you're trying to put your
opponent in check by attacking the
political system. All right? And I'll
show you how later on. Okay? So the king
is political system. The queen is the
grand strategy.
[snorts]
The grand strategy is again how each
player perceives geopolitics and how to
best dominate geopolitics. Okay. And
then you have the bishop, the knight and
the rook. And this are the attack
vectors.
The attack vectors are your mechanisms,
your tools for achieving your grand
strategy.
Right? And now you have the pawn. And
the pawn are just that. They are um
sacrificial
tools
that you can use in order to advance
your grand strategy. Okay? You just
throw them away. You don't really care.
Okay? It doesn't make sense. All right.
So now let's apply this system to the
four nation states. United States,
Russia, Iran, and Israel. All right.
Okay. So
the
United States, the political system of
course is a democracy.
[clears throat]
And this is both good and bad. Okay?
It's good in that it allows for
innovation. It allows for debate and
openness and creativity. Okay? So that's
what's good about democracy. What's bad
about democracy is the idea of
polarization.
Okay? Polarization.
Okay? Why?
Because in a democracy, you have
different political parties and [snorts]
they can reach a point where they just
refuse to work together and all they
care about is destroying each other
regardless of the consequences for the
nation in geopolitics. This is what's
happened United States so far right now
where in America Trump hates the
Democrats much more than he hates the
Russians or the Chinese or the Iranians.
Okay. All right. So the way you put
America into check is by enhancing the
polarization and causing a civil war.
Okay? Does that make sense? You cannot
defeat America militarily.
It is impossible to do so. The only way
to defeat America is if you force it
into a civil war that distracts it from
the world. Okay. So that is um the
American political system. They have the
grand strategy. The grand strategy is
called greater North America.
[clears throat]
And the idea of greater North America is
North America by itself, it's a
self-sufficient continental fortress.
No one can invade it. No one can attack
it. It has all the resources it needs to
survive. So all America has to do is
unite North America
and then cause chaos around the world.
Okay. So what the trick is how to create
unity in um greater North America. And
the theory that they use is something
called the technate.
Right? The idea of the technate is a
democracy is inherently volatile and
unstable. you're better off
transitioning democracy into a
technocracy
ruled by the experts and ruled by AI.
Okay, so basically try to create an AI
surveillance state
which is happening what's happening in
America right now. Okay, something that
we'll discuss in greater detail next
week. All right. So now we go to the
attack vectors of America. What are
their tools and instruments in order to
achieve the grand strategy? Well, the
first major tool is dystopology. Okay?
Meaning that America has um GPS,
satellites, it has uh precision weapons,
it has the best air force in the world,
it has a supremacy. Okay. So, technology
is a very important uh tool. Then you
have
a propaganda.
Propaganda is basically America controls
the world's most powerful media systems
including New York Times including
including CNN. Okay, and therefore it
can control the narrative of the world.
Now last is the US dollar. Okay, the US
dollar is the world's global reserve
currency and therefore America has
unlimited financing.
All right. So, as you can see, America
is a very powerful empire. Now, we go to
the pawns. Okay. The sacrifice
sacrificial tools. And so, what
Americans can sacrifice in order to
achieve its grand strategy are its
allies which are essentially its its um
vassels.
All right. So, that is the American
system.
Right. Now we can we can understand how
America will fight this war in Iran and
how it will proceed to fight World War
II because grand strategy it's just not
only
how
um a nation will go out to dominate the
world but it's also constraint on their
behavior. They can only operate within
the contours of their grand strategy.
Okay, any questions so far?
Okay. All right. So, let us look over
the um tenant of America. So, this is
something that was posted in 1930s and
something that is being implemented
right now in America by the tech roles,
people like um Larry Ellison, Sman,
Peter Theo, Ellen Musk. The idea of
course is to is to unite all of North
America together in in something called
a technate. Okay. The technate is
basically a a force a force sorry
the technate
is
basically this this means an AI
surveillance state. Okay. And this
allows for
uh cohesion and control and once that's
achieved then North America becomes
invincible and it can create as much
chaos as it wants throughout the world.
The goal
is to create chaos so that the world
depends on you for weapons
and resources
and financing.
Okay? And the idea is if the other world
if the entire world is forced to buy
weapons and resources from you and you
can lend money to them to do that then
you get rid of the $39 trillion debt.
Okay? So I'm not saying that this
strategy will work but I'm saying this
is how they approach it. All right. Now
[clears throat] something that is really
important for us to understand is that
a co grand strategy it is based on a
culture of your society. Okay great
strategy is not something that you just
make up. Grand strategy is an expression
a manifestation of your political system
and your cultural system. And we can
understand the cultural system through
the books that are read in society.
Okay. So this is western civilization
right here. So these are four
representative books of Anglo-American
civilization. The first is Paradise Lost
by John Milton. Okay. And parad paradise
loss is very important because it
celebrates individual achievement.
So paradise loss um is about why Adam
and Eve
disobeyed
God. And the argument of paradise laws
is that Adam and Eve disobeyed God
because
they wanted godhood. Okay? they because
of their pride.
And the thing about paradise laws is
that when you read it and we we'll read
a part of it together, you recognize
that pride is a good thing because it
allows us to approach godhood. Okay? So,
it's not bad to want to be God. In fact,
it's a good thing because it it's what
allows for progress. And Hamlet by
Shakespeare is a book that celebrates
indiv individuality, individual
reflection.
Uh, Gertas thaw
is a book in which
a scholar by the name of Foss, he makes
a deal with the devil because he has an
insatiable appetite for knowledge. And
that's a good thing. Okay? He's trying
to achieve godhood himself and this idea
of fostian.
So western civilization especially
Anglo-American civilization is
fundamentally fostian. It's always about
achievement and it's insatiable
achievement.
And the uh the last book I want to
emphasize is the founding head by an ran
which celebrates individualis
individualism. Okay, it celebrates
individual achievement. So to get a
sense of the essence of Anglo-American
culture, I'm going to read to you a
passage from Paradise Lost. And this is
where um Satan disguised as a snake is
trying to convince Eve to eat the fruit
from [snorts] the tree of of knowledge.
Okay? And this is his argument to to
her. Why then was this forbid? Why did
God tell you not to eat from the tree of
knowledge?
Why but to awe?
Why but to keep ye low and ignorant his
worshipper? He knows that in the day ye
thereof your eyes that seem so clear,
yet are but dim shall perfectly be then
open and clear, and you shall be as
gods, knowing both good and evil as they
know." Okay. So this is why God refuses
to let us eat the fruit from the tree of
knowledge of good and evil because if we
can learn for ourselves, we can be like
God. And God created us to be his slaves
and his servants. Okay? That ye shall be
as God since I as man, internal man is
but of proportion meat. I of human ye of
human gods. Okay? So what he's saying is
like think think of this. I'm a snake
and once I eat that fruit I'm able to be
like you. I can speak as well. Now if
you as a human eat that fruit you'll be
a god then.
So ye shall die perhaps by putting off
human to put on gods death to be wished
though threatened which no worse than
this can bring. And what are gods that
men may not become as they participate
in godlike food? What prevents men from
becoming gods? Shouldn't that be a good
thing to be ambitious?
The gods are first and that advantage
used on our belief that all from them
proceeds. Okay. So this is what he's
saying. He's saying like no anyone can
become a god. I'm a snake and I if I can
become human then humans can become gods
as well. But the problem with gods is
that they came first and therefore they
want to maintain the monopoly
over power and that's why they trying to
keep us ignorant. So we have a
responsibility to be ambitious to rebel.
Okay. To rebel. Rebel.
Rebellion is honorable
and just.
Okay. And again this this is the ideas
that permeate throughout Anglo-American
civilization.
I question it for this fear earth I see
worn by the sun producing very every
kind nothing if they all things who
enclose knowledge of good and evil in
this tree that who so eats thereof with
with forth with attains wisdom with
their leave and where in lies the
offense that men should thus attain to
know. What can your knowledge hurt them?
Or this tree impart against his will if
all be his? Or is it envy and can envy
dwell in heavenly breast? These these
and many more causes import your need of
this fair fruit. God is humane reach
them and fairly taste. Okay. If there's
a god that tells us we cannot eat the
fruit, this cannot be the true god
because a god it has to be perfect. It
has to be forgiving. It has to be
generous. And a a and a god that tells
us we cannot do something that denies us
our free will is a god that is jealous
that is petty that is power hungry and
therefore we should rebel against this
god. A rebellion against a tyrant is
honorable and just. Okay. So it's a
celebration of individual
uh in of individual intellect through
rebellion. And this is a basis of
Anglo-American
civilization. Okay. And so
Anglo-American civilization is based
entirely on individual achievement. All
right. Now, Russian civilization is very
different. In fact, it's it's in
opposition in competition with
Anglo-American civilization. Okay. So,
now let's go over to Russia and discuss
the Russian system. So, the Russian
system is an autocracy.
And again, there are strengths and
weaknesses to any political system. And
an autotocracy, if one man is in charge,
that allows for long-term planning, that
allows for direction, that allows for
strategy. Okay? But problem autocracy is
that if this man were to die, you would
have a secession crisis.
So the American strategy to defeat
Russia is not to destroy the country
because you cannot do that. Russia has
nuclear weapons. The strategy is to make
Putin so unpopular
that the elite rise up against Putin and
create a secession crisis. Okay?
Basically to outlast Putin to destroy
his legitimacy. All right. The grand
strategy
for Russia is something called the third
Rome strategy.
All right, I'll discuss this more um
later on. The idea of a third Rome is
that Russia is the here to the Roman
Empire. Okay, the first Rome is Rome,
second Rome is Constantinopole and the
third Rome is Moscow. And there shall be
no fourth Rome. Meaning that once Moscow
achieves the third room, that's the end
of history. And the idea of the third
room is for Russia to unify all
religious traditions together to defeat
the antichrist system which is western
liberal individual consumer democracy.
Okay.
Um the vectors
the attack vectors for Russia's grand
strategy are of course orthodox
religion.
The religion then you have
um the geography
of Russia. So Russia encompasses all
Eurasia and then of course you have the
artillery.
So Russia is basically the world's best
land army and we're seeing that in
Ukraine. Okay. The pawns are soldiers.
In other words,
Russia is not afraid to lose soldiers on
the battlefield. Okay.
All right. So this is um Russia's third
Rome strategy. Okay. So Moscow is the
center of third Rome. And as you can
see, Russia spreads throughout Europe
and throughout Asia. And what Russia is
trying to do is it's trying to re unite
the different religious traditions. So
it's trying to um unite Greek Orthodoxy
with even or orthodoxy. It's trying to
work with the Catholic Church. Okay?
It's and it's trying to work with uh
Israel as well because Israel is also a
religious tradition. Iran
is a very important part of
this third warm strategy. Okay. Iran is
a very important partner of Moscow and
um in the future India could also be a
partner as well because India is Hindu.
Okay. But the great enemy the enemy that
must be destroyed is the Anglo-American
Empire. So the UK and North America and
the idea is to cause them to go into
civil war. The theory is that um because
the Anglo-American Empire is so focused
on individual achievement, you can
actually force them into a civil war by
exploiting the selfishness, the egotism
of the people. Okay? Basically the
material greed of their people.
So what underpins
Moscow's third Rome strategy are certain
texts. Okay. So you have Virgil's iniad
which focuses on the importance of duty.
Okay. Duty.
Then you have St. Augustine's
confessions
and in his
uh book he argues that
we humans are proud. Okay. But whereas
John Milton says pride is a good thing
but allows us to achieve godhood. Um
says that pride is evil because pride
moves us away from God. It makes us
think we're better than God. So it moves
us to Satan. Therefore,
our life should be a journey into
defeating our ego, our selfishness and
our pride and embracing God. Okay, this
something that um twice uh sorry, Dossi
talks about in his book Crime and
Punishment. So, Crime in the in the um
book Crime and Punishment, the
protagonist wants to become a
superhuman. He he wants to prove he's
better than everyone else. And so to do
that, he decides to commit murder. Okay?
He wants to show himself and to others
that he is beyond morality,
that he is a god. He's not constrained
by emotions. And so he kills
um his um landl. But then afterwards, he
feels tremendous regret for what he did.
And what saves him [clears throat] is
his love for another for a woman. Okay?
He submits himself to the power of love.
He submits himself to the power of God
and that's what redeems him in the end.
Okay? So the argument here is that your
belief in your own possibility
of achieving godhood can only lead you
to your own doom. Okay. What will save
you? What will redeem you is to
omit your mortality,
omit your fallibility, and to seek help
from those around you and from God.
Okay.
All right. So,
um this is something that Toy Story
talks also about in his book Anacarina.
Okay. So, we're going to read a passage
from Anacarina.
And Anacrinina
is a woman who's obsessed with
um finding love and she believes that
through passion,
through devotion, I can find true love
and therefore complete myself. Okay. So
she has an affair with a man named Count
Ronssky. And in the beginning it's a
wonderful thing. It brings her
tremendous happiness. She leaves her
husband. she leaves her um son. But
eventually what she discovers is that
this lust for another for man
in order to fill the void in her heart
makes her even more empty and um she
feels her life becomes more and more
pointless. Okay. So she decides to kill
herself. But before she kills herself,
she has this internal monologue with
herself. Okay? And this this what she
says. My love keeps growing more
passionate and more e egoistic, more
selfish, more proud while his is waning
and waning and that's why we're drifting
apart. Okay. So she demands Krosky
love her as much as she loves him. The
problem is that she doesn't recognize
that this love, it's not about love.
It's about control. Okay?
She wants him to be as devoted to her as
she is to him. Okay? She wants to
control him and he rebelss against his
control. Okay? And so he starts to drift
away because he wants to maintain his
freedom.
[snorts] She went on and there's no help
for it. He has everything everything for
me. I want to I want him more and more
to give himself up to me entirely. Okay.
So she wants him to surrender himself
completely to her. She wants to become
God and she he wants she wants to make
him the servant. Okay. This is not about
love. It's about power
and he wants more and more to get away
from me. We walk to meet each other
up to the time of our love and then we
have been irrespons
and there's no altering that. He tells
me I'm insanely jealous and I have told
myself that I am insanely jealous but
it's not true. I'm not jealous but I'm
unsatisfied.
Okay. But she opened her lips and
shifted her place in the carriage in the
excitement aroused by the thought that
suddenly struck her. If I could be
anything but a mistress passionately
caring for nothing but his caresses. But
I can't and I don't care to be anything
else. And by the desire I rouse aversion
in him and he rouses fury in me and it
cannot be different. Don't I know that
he wouldn't deceive me? That he has no
schemes about Princess Shakina that he's
not in love with Kitty that he won't
desert me. I know all that. But it makes
me it makes it no better for me. Without
loving me from duty, he'll be good and
kind to me. Without what I want, that's
a thousand times worse than unkindness.
That's hell. That's just how it is. for
a long while now he hasn't loved me and
where love ends hate begins. I don't
know these streets at all. Hills it
seems and steel houses. Okay. And so
she's going to go kill herself because
she recognizes that she's been living a
lie. She thought that if I truly love
him
then he will love me back.
She wants to become God. And what she
doesn't recognize is that as a human,
she has an ego. And so when you she
thinks she's loving Kronsky
unconditionally, but in fact, what what
she's trying to do is control him
and have him obey her unconditionally.
Okay, that's the difference between God
and human where God God is all knowing,
all forgiving, all generous, all love.
But a human can't do that. And when a
human tries to become a god, a human can
only become a tyrant.
Okay? And that's a lesson from Toy
Story. Don't think you can you can
become God. You can only destroy
yourself as well as others around you.
And so what um uh Toy Story will do is
that he will contrast Anacrina with a
man named Levan. Okay. And Levan is
different. Levan rather than trying to
seek happiness and passion, he just
submits himself to duty and to to
tradition. He marries a woman he loves
and he spends all his time being
responsible to her as well as to himself
as well as to the household. He just
does what he's supposed to do. And by
doing that, by submitting his freedom,
by
submitting himself to duty and
tradition, he makes himself truly happy.
Okay? So really the argument between
America and Russia is a difference
understanding of the story of Adam and
Eve. For the Americans, they believe
that Eve's disobedience is a good thing
because it's what leads to to progress.
It's what leads to um um
achievement.
Americans believe that godhood is
possible and it's a good thing. The
Russians are different. They believe
that Eve disobeyed because she was too
proud and she does not recognize the
limitations
of her humanity.
and perfection is not possible. Progress
is not possible. What is good is
recognizing our limitations and
submitting ourselves to the power of
God. Okay? So that's why Russia and
America cannot reconcile because not
only do they have geopolitical
differences, but fundamentally the way
they perceive the world is different and
they're fighting to impose their own
reality on others. Okay. All right.
[snorts] But the same is also true for
Iran and Israel. Okay. So now let's go
over Iran.
Iran is a theocracy. A theocracy is good
in that
it creates cohesion in society
and
they are able to survive major
calamities because of their faith. Okay.
So even though even though Americans and
Israelis are destroying a lot of Iranian
infrastructure, the the Iranian people
are still united. But the theocracy is
bad because it can lead to extremism
and extremism can divide a population.
Okay? So it's possible that this war
continues, you have a small minority of
the population who become who become
extremists and they alienate everyone
else. Okay.
Um the grand strategy
is Shia exceptionalism.
And the idea here is that the Iranians
are Shia Muslims.
And Shia Muslims believe that only a
descendant of the prophet Muhammad can
lead the Muslim world can become califf.
Okay?
And the Sunni Muslims who are the
majority in the Muslim world don't
believe that. They believe that anyone
who's qualified can become califf. So
for the longest time, the Shia and the
Sunnis have been at war with each other.
And um Saudi Arabia
is the center of the Sunni Muslim world
and uh Iran is the center of the Shia
Muslim world. And so what Iran is trying
to do is topple Saudi Arabia and become
the leader of the entire Muslim world
because that is what their destiny is.
Okay. Um, the attack vectors for Iran
are the terrain,
uh, their faith
and the proxies. Okay. The proxies
include um the Houthis, the um,
Hezbollah and Hamas. Okay. And the drone
and and the pawns of course are the
drones and missiles.
All right. So that is the Iranian
situation and what's important to
understand is the cultural origins.
Okay. Sorry. So um this is the entire
Muslim world and what Iran is trying to
do is trying to unite all of them
together. Okay. Um so
something to really something you need
to appreciate about the Iranians is that
they have two major cultural traditions.
The first is Zoroastrianism.
And Zorastronism was the first
esquetological religion in the world and
that they believe that there is an end
of the world judgment day. And at
judgment day, those who live the truth,
Asha will desend will ascend to heaven
and those who live the lie, the Jews,
will descend into hell. So what's
important is not to become wealthy or
powerful or famous. It's not about
achievement. It's about being true to
yourself and being true to God. Okay? To
to live a good life because at the end
of time you'll be rewarded. Okay? That's
what they believe. The other thing is
they believe in martyrdom. Okay?
So as I mentioned the Shia believed that
only the descendant only a blood
relative of the prophet Muhammad can be
khalif. So this is um Ian Hussein who's
a grandson of the prophet
and he rebelled against the califf and
so the califf had this huge army against
him and he was surrounded and he had
very few soldiers but they fought to the
death anyway okay because they believe
what's important is to die for your for
your for your faith and so this is a
battle of Carbala
And so in other words, because of these
traditions, you have both the Zashian
tradition that believe in judgment day.
You also have the Shia um tradition
which believes in martyrdom. The
Iranians are not afraid to fight to the
death. Yes, the Americans and Israelis
have bigger weapons. They have more
soldiers. They have more money. It
doesn't matter. what's important is to
fight for what to believe in to set a
good example for future generations.
Okay? So that's a that's a Iranian
system and that's why the Iranians will
not will never surrender in this war no
matter how bad it gets. [snorts] The
last I want to talk the last country I
want to talk about is Israel.
Okay. So Israel it is not it is a
democracy and a theocracy. Okay.
Sorry. [clears throat]
Okay. So, this is a democracy as well as
a theocracy.
And the way you destroy Israel is you
cause it in you cause it to enter a
civil war. All right? And it's actually
not that hard because right now Israel
is a very fractured society.
Um, the grand strategy is something
called the Greater Israel Project.
So the the Israelis believe that
in the Bible it says that God promised
their ancestor Abraham all the Middle
East stretching from the Nile to the
Euphrates and that's what they must
achieve. Okay? So they're fighting this
war not to defeat Iran but to achieve
the greater Israel project. The attack
vectors are the Bible,
the Mossad
and the Jewish diaspora.
Okay. So, Israel doesn't have that many
people, 8 n million people. It's a very
small country, but it has three major
advantages. The first advantage is the
Bible. And that there are many
Christians who believe that Israel
is what God promised the Jewish people
and therefore the Jewish people have a
right to be in Israel and do whatever
they want because that is what God
promised them. Okay.
Um then you have Mossad. And so MSAD is
the most effective intelligence agency
in the world. And what they're very good
at doing is infiltration
infiltration.
And they're so they're good at
co-opting, bribing, and blackmailing
the elites of different nations. And
this is especially true in the Middle
East. Okay? And then you have the
diaspora. Um the Jews are everywhere
around the world. and that so they
become very um important
recruits from Assad, but they're they're
also very wealthy so they can finance
Israel and its mission to create the
greater Israel project. And of course,
the pawns are everyone else.
Okay. So, Msad is very good at
infiltrating different nations and
creating conflict in those nations in
order to benefit Israel. All right.
Okay.
So this is the greater Israel project
and this is the end goal of the
Israelis. All right. So the good is
project stretches from the Nile to the
Euphrates. What's important is that it
also encompasses parts of Turkey, all of
Syria, all of Jordan, Lebanon,
and parts of Saudi Arabia. Okay?
[snorts] And then Iraq as well. So this
war in the Middle East is actually
helping Israel move towards the Greater
Israel project because what is happening
is that Iran is basically destroying
the GCC. Okay? And maybe
uh Turkey will enter the war at some
point in which case this will make
Turkey vulnerable to attack
uh from Israel. Okay. So what Israel is
very good at doing is are creating false
flag operations.
False flag operations. And the idea is
that listen what you want is the entire
Middle East at war with each with each
other. So you create as much conflict as
possible, right? So so idea is that the
Iranians don't actually have to attack
the GCC because they assume this will do
it for them and and blame it on the
Iranians. Okay? So this conflict will
only get worse and worse because it
benefits Israel to have as much conflict
as possible in the Middle East. Okay?
And underpinning [clears throat]
um Israel society is something called
the Cabala.
Right?
[snorts]
So this is something called the tree of
life and I'll explain more later on in
the semester about what the cabala is
because it's very important. But there
are certain things I'll point out about
the cabala. Okay. The first thing that
I'll point out is that
in the tradition of the cabala there's
only two things that matter. There's the
creator and there's the created.
Okay.
In other words,
Israel does not care about the world.
Israel only cares about it relationship
with God. As long as Israel is favored
by God, they're happy. Okay, that's the
first thing I'll point out. Second thing
I'll point out is that
this
cabala, the tree of life,
it is the basis for the entire universe.
Okay, this cabala shows you where the
universe came from and where it's going.
And the main logic of the universe is
the movement of thesis,
antithesis
and synthesis.
Okay, this is the fractal that underpins
the cure of life which underpins entire
universe. Okay, you can see how
um you have these factors going on.
Okay.
Okay. So in other words, what what the
people believe in the cabala believe is
that there is an inedible process to the
universe
and you can't stop it. What you can do
is you can accelerate the process.
All right?
So if the movement is thesis in
antithesis symphysis,
one way to understand this is for for us
to be good, we must first be evil. Okay?
Because what evil does is it annoys God
and God punishes you. Then you seek
forgiveness from God and then God
forgives you and then you become better.
But the but the thing to the thing to
remember is you must first commit sin in
order to redeem yourself
and you can't stop this process. What
you can do is you can accelerate this
process. So this is very different from
the Russian tradition. The Russian
tradition believes in the concept of the
catacon
right which is to stop the antichrist
which is like let's stop people from
behaving badly. Whereas the people in
the cabala believe no it's important to
behave badly because that is the path to
God. That's the path to wisdom. That's a
path to enlightenment and redemption.
Okay. It's something that we'll discuss
more in the future. Okay. And this helps
us explain why Israel is behaving the
way it is behaving in the Middle East.
First of all, what other people think of
Israel doesn't matter. What matters is
God. Okay? What God thinks of Israel.
Second thing is that
it's important to do evil in order to
ultimately redeem yourself from this
evil. And the only force that can redeem
you is God. Okay? So Israel is
committing all this evil because then
God will humble is Israel by sending the
world against it and then the Israelites
will beg for forgiveness and that is
what will um cause reunion between the
Jewish people and God. Okay. And the
third thing is
in the system
goodness does not mean to avoid sin.
It's impossible. Goodness means to
accelerate this natural process into sin
so that Israel can be redeemed at the
end of days. Okay. Does that make sense?
All right. So what what I'm trying to
explain here and what this is very
important is that each of these four
different players United States, Russia,
Iran and Israel, they have their own
worldview. They they have own
understanding and that's what drives
their actions.
Okay. And [snorts] the other thing to
remember is that what's really
interesting between these four
worldviews is that they're actually not
in conflict with each other. Okay. And
these four and these four world views,
it's going it's what's going to drive
geopolitics for the next 5 to 10 years.
And because they are galvanized into
achieving their worldview, this forces
the world to go along even though the
world may not want to go along. Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. So um
what I will do next week is talk about
the civil war going on going on in the
world between artificial intelligence
and finance. Okay. And Trump is visiting
China in about a week's time. So we'll
also look at the relationship between
the United States and China as well.
Okay. Any questions? All
right.